uh let us bring in now uh and get some
legal analysis Jonathan Turley uh law
professor and Fox News contributor
Jonathan uh we're reading uh we now have
multiple sources telling us that there
are 10 indictments named here uh again
an educated guess I think we know the
name certainly at the top of the list
would be president Donald J Trump this
would now be his fourth indictment
um one big difference that we would see
in this case probably versus the other
three previous indictments would be uh
Georgia Sunshine laws likelihood of this
being on television uh is probably great
will that be impactful to the American
people more so than the other cases
well we'll be the other big distinction
is that the cases brought by Jack Smith
are subject to presidential pardon
including the possibility of a
self-pardon by Donald Trump if he's
re-elected the New York and Georgia
cases are not subject to Federal pardon
Authority uh the suggestion is that
there are not just 10 indictments but
that it's based on Rico and that's a
favorite tool of this particular
prosecutor it requires a pattern to be
shown usually a fraud that ties these
people together this is a lot of of
indictment obviously if you've got 10
defendants that is also similar to a lot
of criminal Rico statutes uh but they
really the the danger here is that it
can dilute the legitimacy of the case
unless you can show strong linkages on a
case of this kind you don't want it to
look like you're charging everyone and
letting God sort them out and so we have
to see what evidence that they actually
turned up one of the most concerning
aspects about this particular
investigation and there's a number of
them is that it began after the
disclosure of the call of Donald Trump
to Georgia election officials that call
has been widely misrepresented in my
view in the call of President Trump at
the time I said you only need to find
around 11 000 votes and that has been
taken as an invitation for fraud I there
is of course a more obvious explanation
and that is the Georgia officials were
saying that further State recounts might
not be necessary and it would be natural
for Trump to say look you only need to
find eleven thousand uh to turn the
outcome of this election so I don't need
that many votes thus a state recount is
Justified now either of those
interpretations can be believed by
citizens but you usually need something
more clear to establish a criminal case
to me the more innocent explanation is
the more obvious one
yeah let me let me ask you first of all
uh content indictments could it be more
than 10 people in other words could
there be multiple people uh or would
that number 10 be the number of people
yeah it's hard to say because in the
vernacular that people use it could be
individual defendants uh it does not
appear to be a reference to the accounts
there's been uh other leaks saying that
we have dozens of counts here I we don't
know much quite frankly about what's in
this uh indictment against Donald Trump
if there is such an indictment we expect
there is there have been suggestions
that the call will be featured
prominently there's also been references
to a controversy involving Coffee County
this was where the Trump team gained
access to one of the voting machines now
you have to keep in mind that back then
and you and I were doing the coverage uh
the Trump team was trying to get access
to these machines because they were
alleging that the machines could be
manipulated and that votes could be
flipped apparently someone and they she
now may be one of these defendants gave
them access to machines Inc Coffee
County that has been alleged to be a
breach of security of that machine it
was after the election but the machines
were still being controlled obviously uh
by the election officials the problem
with that is that the emails that we've
read to the Trump team say that we got
an invitation uh to to see one of these
machines and that there's been a
voluntary access granted
she's going to need something more than
that right she's going to need to show
that there was a knowing Criminal Intent
here not just by some of these
individuals in Georgia but of Donald
Trump himself
yeah let me let me just remind people
what has happened here
um we now have uh what has been
unfolding in the last 17 minutes is that
the grand jury that worked late into the
night tonight up until the moment we're
coming on the air uh has come up with
what we believe now reported widely 10
indictments uh signed by the judge filed
with the clerk and what we're now
discovering and finding out a little
color behind the scenes here uh the
clerk was asked about any names or
charges in the indictment because you
know remember it was signed by a judge
and filed with the clerk and the clerk
just told reporters that we would hear
uh what is in this and the what are in
these indictments tonight uh worst case
scenario quote three hours a
representative from Fulton County
Superior Court Clerk's Office
representative from The Fulton County
DA's office and several representatives
from The Fulton County Sheriff's Office
have walked into the courtroom A.D and
that's Judge Robert mcburney's courtroom
uh and so all of this is now unfolding
behind the scenes which basically means
at any point we can uh we can be uh
informed of what it is that they that
the grand jury was actually working late
into the night for let me go back to
this issue of Rico and racketeering
conspiracy uh which we have heard a lot
about in the in the days and even weeks
now leading up to what was fairly
inevitable in Fulton County
um usually when you hear Rico
racketeering you think about those those
were designed to go after specifically
the mob how do you come up with a RICO
conspiracy charge racketeering charge
how do you how do you foresee the
arguments going down in that way
well it has been expanded for use beyond
the mob what you have to show is that a
predicate offense one of the offenses
listed in the state statute I has
occurred and that there's a pattern of
those crimes two or three linked
together uh is enough to establish a
RICO conspiracy they're clearly looking
into electoral fraud and possible
forgery and other crimes that may be
practical alleged as predicate offenses
the thing about Rico prosecutions is
that they are a favorite of not just
many prosecutors but this particular
prosecutor Willis sort of cut her teeth
on uh Rico cases she brought a very
famous case of against a group of
teachers so this is sort of in her
wheelhouse the question however is still
those interstitial links those connect
actions between these predicate offenses
and these defendants uh how strong are
they we haven't heard any direct
linkages to criminal conduct by Donald
Trump we'll have to see what they have
uh and whether she was able to you know
to to cross that Rubicon uh but with 10
people there's also added pressure on
some defendants to flip you know it's a
very common Rico uh tactic among
prosecutors uh to charge everyone and
see if some of these low-hanging fruit
defendants I will decide that they're
better off giving States evidence you
know usually these charges come with
heavy penalties
all right Fox News contributor and of
course law professor Jonathan Turley he
will be staying with us throughout the
hour tonight thank you stand by we'll be
getting back to you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else